[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
so was that stupid droid of yours gonna
come through or not
well I'm beginning to think I was a
little better off in myself
hey what do you know a little cargo
cylinder came through if he got the
turbolifts working then we should have a
clear run to the hangar don't tell me
you're taking that hatch down into the
mining tunnels are you that explosion I
heard came from below there's probably
nothing down there except superheated
rock and collapsed blast tunnels you'd
be an idiot to go down there you're
either really brave or really crazy or
both all right I'll try to monitor
things from up here and be careful the
only thing moving down there is likely
to be mining droids so don't be playing
hero too hard
ah not that I care what happens to you
or anything I just don't want to be
trying to get off this rock by myself
I'll keep the comlink open I may be able
to guide you through the tunnels from up
here don't know if the signal will hold
if you get too deep though
[Music]
[Music]
you